next question today is about the economy
David how is Donald Trump still polling
better than Joe Biden on the economy
this is a really good question and it
gets to a lot of the way that
Republicans have operated for a very
long time you've got a recession going
on
Trump is down eight nine ten twelve
points nationally to Joe Biden and yet
he is still polling better than Biden on
the economy morning consult has Trump
plus nine on the economy CNN has Trump
plus twelve on the economy YouGov has
Trump plus five a Quinnipiac says Biden
is plus one on the economy but that's
way less than on basically every other
issue for Biden Harvard Harris Poll says
Trump is plus ten on the economy so a
couple different things number one the
the lead is diminishing so if you look
at the trend line Trump is leading Biden
by less and less on handling the economy
over time there is a meme there's a
tendency to think that Republicans are
just better on the economy than
Democrats now the reality is that that's
a historical we did a analysis we did an
analysis earlier this week about the
stock market under Democrats versus
Republicans does far better under
Democrats than under Republicans
unemployment tends to be lower we've
looked at all the numbers but in
practice Trump also doesn't know a damn
thing about the economy Trump didn't
know about currency valuations he called
Michael Flynn at 3:00 a.m. and said do
we want a weak currency or a strong
currency which is good and Flynn said
talk to an economist Trump has no idea
on trade Trump believes that the stock
market tells us how an economy is doing
so part of it is that a lot of voters
also think those same things Trump
thinks to figure out how the economy is
doing you look at the stock market a lot
of voters think the same thing and in
fact they tweet me all the time and say
the economy is doing great because the
stock market is doing great a lot of
what also needs to be considered is that
Republicans tend to do things
economically that will have a short term
focus how many jobs can we
create this month even though reopening
early will hurt the economies in the
long run and a lot of the jobs jobs are
crappy right how many stock market
points can we gain today even its if
it's with cash injections that are
short-sighted and won't really improve
the economy in the long run so that's a
really important thing also to consider
which is Republicans are far more likely
than Democrats to do things that improve
the optics of the economy in the short
term but don't really improve it in the
long term and this is where a lot of
this translates into the general belief
that Republicans are just better for
your paycheck you know better for your
pocketbook or better for your bank
account it's mathematically untrue but
unfortunately these memes are pretty
sticky and just remember the fact stocks
do better under Democrats unemployment
is lower under Democrats just about
every economic indicator we've looked at
a bunch of others although I'm
forgetting them now they look better
under Democrats and we shouldn't allow
them to take the narrative away and the
diminishing lead that Donald Trump has
on Joe Biden in terms of expected
handling of the economy is a sign that
at least the disastrous economic
situation we have right now is affecting
Donald Trump we thought maybe he's
Teflon Teflon Don maybe nothing will
affect him coronavirus the subsequent
economic collapse and his reaction to
the protests against police brutality
have hurt him very much his approval
down to 38%